[Music]
sean you and i were sent something from
our friend jack steph i'll fill you in
so basically there's this guy named ryan
cohen ryan cohen he started chewie.com
which is a like amazon for pet stuff
when he was young right sean i think he
was like in his early 20s
and he was aggressive when he started it
he raised a ton of money he started out
of florida so he was very much like an
individual thinker he was like no we're
not doing silicon valley we're gonna do
this out of florida he raised like a
billion dollars a huge sum ended up
selling it for three four five six
billion i don't know the exact amount
then it goes public
worth uh many billions but
after doing that he made i think around
like 600 million dollars like a huge
amount of money
and after he made that money there was
an article written where he goes i
pretty much put all of my money into two
stocks apple and wells fargo so he put
like all of it in there
and since that article went live that
means that the money that he put in
there has gone up 361
then about
a year and a half ago
he noticed that there was a brand that
he loved that wasn't doing so well and
he thought these guys could totally
revolutionize the game but they're just
really like getting they're getting
crushed right now i'm gonna buy 10 of
the company which he did for 76 million
dollars and that company was gamestop
and when he bought gamestop that's when
this whole
like meme stock thing went down because
everyone was like brian cohen bought it
and he actually it worked he turned the
company around or at least it's in the
process but it's being turned around and
his 76 million dollars he turned into
1.1 billion and he currently still owns
like 13 of the companies on their board
of directors now
just this morning it was released or
announced that he just bought
10 percent of bed bath and beyond
so he's doing the same thing and this
guy is a madman i think i'm almost
positive he's still only 34 35 years old
i also researched on linkedin i'm almost
positive that it's just him like he
doesn't have an employee
maybe as an assistant but it's like just
him like searching around for stuff so
this man's crazy and i love him
so his money's already up
uh yeah okay he's amazing i feel like
there should be
like a ticker for just like stocks
that aren't small that have fallen like
80 plus percent from their highs it's
like what crazy operators want to like
come in here and totally turn this thing
around i feel like you could also have a
podcast about that where you just like
you find a stock like bed bath and
beyond and you're like look highs were
at 80 it's now at what was it before
this like six dollars like what would
you do if you were operating this
business and have people like come on
and battle like jeopardy style and see
who comes out with the best strategy
that's kind of cool yeah right now
there's like a whole bunch of growth
stocks that are down you know somewhere
between 50 and 80 percent from their
all-time high
and you know stocks like zoom and
uh you know
vastly and a bunch of others
and uh
there's you know there's like kind of
that one buffett phrase you know be uh
be greedy when others are fearful and
fearful when others are greedy
and uh
it sure does seem like now is a good
time to be greedy when others are
fearful right like uh there's a lot of
you know opportunity everywhere in the
market and so you know if these are
things that you believe in
on a 10-year time scale then like this
is a fantastic entry point
uh here's another interesting one so
i was thinking about this bed bath and
beyond thing and game stock and my
friend joe sent this to me so have you
guys remember express
yeah i don't know if they if they have
that in canada stuff but express mostly
women's clothes it's like it was like
fast fa fast fashion before that was
like even called the thing so
look at what their market cap is i think
their market cap is 250 million dollars
right now but their ebitda is 150
million
so i think express is an interesting one
too yeah but you got to look at like the
debt and all all these other obligations
they haven't they have a ton of debt yes
they have a ton of debt that's the
problem they've got a ton of time jack
was a ryan cohen is basically he's doing
the tai lopez playbook of buying old
retailers and
spinning them into like you know
e-commerce and sort of rejuvenating
these big old brands
you know he's doing the same playbook as
tai lopez just without being tai lopez
which is actually
a great idea in general that's a great
business plan to follow
do the tai lopez playbook without being
tai lopez is like a a great great idea
when people talk about buying when the
like buy buy the dip i hate that i'm
because i'm like i don't i don't have
any money to buy chew the dip
yeah that's what i gotta do
i don't know whenever people say buy the
dip i'm like
with what i i don't own anything what do
you what do i do you don't keep any uh
dry powder i feel like you always you're
always mr like safety net with cash and
other things you have dry powder why
aren't you buying the dip
i have a hundred thousand dollars in
cash oh wow okay i think you used to
have way more in cash
now there's now that's your short-term
real estate mobile you've deployed
everything or what
i've deployed everything yeah i don't i
yeah i don't have that much cash i don't
have enough what do people just hold
like keep cash in a checking account
yeah certainly people do that they do
cds they do you know different like
different versions of
like a market neutral like you know cash
position
i own bonds i own a ton of bonds seven
figures of bonds but
i guess
who told you to do that
uh it's
five percent of my net worth is
impossible who told you to do that
don't nobody buys bonds on their own
everybody gets told to buy bots
my my a lot of my portfolio is 90 10. so
90 equities 10 percent bonds you're not
you don't play do you own a bond i don't
know a single bond
steph do you
i don't own a single bond really but i
feel like sean's right like what what
rate are you getting on these bonds
aren't interest rates at like zero
yeah nothing like two percent
yeah i don't know it's just like
traditional yourself into a money losing
position congratulations
well actually that's a good question
with with havoc going on right now sean
from one is your net worth down from one
year ago today if assuming you did not
add any new cash
yeah for sure one year ago because one
year ago was like a market high right
like uh if you're talking about right
after the covet bounce so like let's say
kovid crash then covert recovery all
happened in like a three month period or
six month period basically so let's just
take the all-time high last year to
today
i gotta be down
25 30 percent easily easily 30 percent
i would have thought it would have been
a lot more because of you have more
high-risk stuff
uh yeah but like a lot of myself's in
amazon stock and amazon stock has done
fine you know it's down a little bit but
uh
yes that one's not so bad and i would
say like you know that's a pretty large
position so that's not super that's not
very risky in my opinion and um
you know crypto
cryptos you know
down one over 30 30 35 from last year
most of it but i have a few like altcoin
bets that have done really well so like
uh i was on here talking about luna not
long ago luna's up 100 so it's like you
know that that doubled while other stuff
went down 30 so it's okay you know we do
all right
but sean where's your psychology at
because i feel like you know everyone
knows the strategy like yeah buy low
sell high but when this actually happens
when all your stocks or all your
investments go down it's like so hard to
actually maintain that psychology and be
like oh yeah i'm totally gonna put more
more money in the market so are you like
is your conviction still as strong as it
used to be are you like yeah this is
like awesome i'm going to buy the dip or
are you struggling
quick interruption do me a favor
scroll down and you're going to see a
link to the hustle so if you want to
stay up to date on the tech and business
news you need to know check out the
hustle it's a daily email i used to help
write it i love it so check it out
scroll down below
let me guess don't talk sean don't talk
yet i have a feeling that this means
nothing to you and you're totally cool
about this uh it's actually even better
i don't even look like i don't look at
it because i'm like oh why would i look
it's just gonna be down so i just don't
look which means i don't think about it
which is actually like the correct way i
should have been doing it all together
like waking up and seeing green
put a nice little pep in my step but was
sort of this like false uh positive
and um
and now i just don't look because i'm
like oh yeah of course i'm down five
percent again today like what i just
lose five percent every day or two
percent every day that's just like a an
average day now so i just don't even
look at it and because i'm not looking
at it it doesn't matter because i wasn't
selling i wasn't selling when it was
going up but i'm not selling when it's
going down so it doesn't really matter
the day-to-day fluctuations of it so now
it's just i just get some time back
because i don't like
want to go look at it because i don't
want to see any carnage so i'll just
like kind of ignore it and just go about
my my day and uh you know i kind of
asked i'll pause i'll ask myself you
know has anything changed meaning do i
view these investments differently now
do i no longer believe that these are
good good investments to be in over like
a five to ten year period no okay so
then you know what am i thinking about
there's nothing nothing nothing to think
about essentially at this time do i buy
the dip uh that's one where you know
sometimes i do like to just chill and
just like sit on the sideline for a bit
um
because i'm a pretty like
i've spent a lot of time in my life
gambling like i literally played a lot
of poker a lot like i've spent so many
days in a casino and so i know the
feeling of chasing a loss trying to win
it back and um and so i just like to
make sure that i'm not doing that so
there's a difference between buying the
dip and chasing a loss
um
and you know throwing good money in
after bad and so just trying to
differentiate between the two like am i
on tilt or
do i actually believe that you know this
is a good good entry point and you know
whatever else so i would say the one
thing this does do is it heightens my
focus on earning money because like oh i
need to like earn money i can't just
rely on my investments you know
completely so like what do you know i
got off my ass i taught my course and i
like submit my invoice for for the
podcast and i like i do things that like
will bring cash in because otherwise you
know
it's easy to get lazy when when
everything's just going up so much right
there's many days where you could just
look at your portfolio and just be like
wow that was a whole year's worth of
salary just today swing like swing up so
that kind of makes you kind of lazy to
like do the work that day in a way right
because it's like
oh well this if this just could earn
that much money just doing nothing every
day like why do i need to go hustle for
that you know that next dollar i feel
like yeah i feel like a lot of people
are feeling that way they're like oh
right i have to work like this doesn't
matter which is very healthy very
healthy position to be in
[Music]